on va parler des assises de
l'alimentation début février le
département des Yvelines lancé ses
premières assises de l'alimentation
l'objectif favoriser la production
locale et faire progresser les circuits
courts alors 4 mois après quel est le
bilan pour en parler avec nous Pauline
vinocourt le faire pour commencer
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui vous a
poussé à créer ses premières assises de
l'alimentation pourquoi il y en a pas eu
avant et c'est cette année que vous avez
décidé de les lancer
alors ça pourquoi il y en a pas eu avant
Joker en tout cas la raison sérieusement
la raison pour laquelle on les a lancé
enfin il y a plusieurs raisons d'abord
on a mis en place il y a quelques années
un système original pour alimenter les
cantines de nos collèges une structure
qui s'appelle ce midi et qui a la
différence d'une simple délégation de
services publics on a un prestataire
mais on siège avec lui dans le conseil
d'administration de la sémop société
d'économie mixte à objet unique
et l'un des objectifs de ces midi
c'était d'avoir plus de produits locaux
dans les assiettes de des collégiens
pour travailler avec nos producteurs et
pas ce qu'on considère que ça a aussi du
sens de consommer local et que ça peut
pérenniser restructurer des filières et
soutenir nos agriculteurs qui en ont
quand même bien besoin
ensuite se pose aujourd'hui avec sans
doute plus d'acuité qui a quelques
années la question de la souveraineté
alimentaire sur laquelle on a décidé de
travailler à l'échelle de notre
territoire donc plus de local dans les
assiettes de collégiens au départ mais
soutenir nos agriculteurs ensuite et
avant tout et travailler sur cette
question de la souveraineté alimentaire
alors bien sûr à l'échelle d'un
territoire on peut pas forcément
répondre à tous les besoins avec les
producteurs yvelinois peut-être parce
qu'il y a certains produits qu'on n'a
pas suffisamment dans les Yvelines on
s'interdit pas évidemment de travailler
à l'échelle régionale ou en proximité
avec des départements limitrophes quand
c'est nécessaire évidemment alors on le
sait les coups de production sont
nettement moins élevés pour les grands
groupes industriels c'est l'une des
raisons pour lesquelles les Français
décident de moins manger local ou de
moins privilégier les circuits courts
comment est-ce que vous comptez
accroître justement ces circuits courts
et les petits producteurs sans
présenter les tarifs et notamment pour
les cantines alors dans les cantines du
département le prix de l'assiette
augmente sensiblement quand même à
partir du moment où faire entrer plus de
produits locaux
voilà parce que il y a les coûts de
production mais pas que quand on parle
de circuit court on parle à la fois de
proximité et de
d'intermédiaires c'est-à-dire que le
circuit court c'est aussi celui qui va
le plus rapidement possible du champ à
l'assiette or toujours l'exemple des
carottes parce qu'il est assez
emblématique et que les collégiens
mangent des carottes
la carotte les carottes qui sont
produites chez nos producteurs il est
bien évident qu'ils peuvent pas aller on
a 115 collèges dans les Yvelines ils
peuvent pas aller en livrer 3 kilos par
ci 18 kg par là etc donc on a besoin
d'un maillon logistique parce que c'est
pas notre métier parce que c'est pas
celui de du prestataire de restauration
donc ça
voilà c'est c'est aussi c'est aussi un
sujet après pour ce qui est du
consommateur il y avait effectivement un
groupe de travail il y avait huit
groupes de travail dans ces assises un
sur l'aristocaux et un sur la
fidélisation des consommateurs parce
qu'on a constaté après le covid pendant
le covid les gens sont allés dans leur
ferme acheter ce qu'il fallait le temps
alors Isabelle le temps
aller au supermarché au début de la
crise covid c'était assez anxiogène
finalement
et je pense aussi que c'était l'occasion
de sortir de prendre l'air et de signer
son petit bon de sortie et d'aller se
balader dans la campagne après le covid
beaucoup de producteurs qui font de la
vente à faire ou qui ont des boutiques
en vente directe nous disent on est
retombé à un niveau plus bas qu'avant
covid donc il y a sûrement la question
du temps de l'accessibilité et puis la
question du prix et dans les groupes de
dans le groupe de travail sur ces sujets
là il y avait aussi la difficulté
parfois à trouver les produits à savoir
beaucoup en parle nous dans les Yvelines
on les a déjà référencé on met à jour la
liste des producteurs d'autres
structures l'ont fait je sais qu'à la
région ils ont une liste régionale
certaines intercos comme GPSO ont listé
aussi leurs producteurs donc il y a une
réflexion sur le ou les outils qu'on
pourrait mettre au service alors
peut-être des communes peut-être des
intercos en tout cas du plus grand
nombre pour faire connaître ses
producteurs c'est vrai que c'est aussi
un sujet après la question du coup
effectivement
c'est l'équation compliquée à résoudre
il faut en passer par là il faut en
passer par là mais dans nos assises on
sait aussi penché sur le sujet de la
précarité alimentaire pour voir comment
dans les circuits de distribution
alimentaire pour les plus fragiles on
pouvait avoir plus de produits locaux
aussi justement vous commencez à
travailler sur ces questions des coûts
vous avez des petites billes pour pour
peut-être les réduire petit à petit et
puis qu'on enlève un petit peu cette
image de mon dessin manger local c'est
accessible que au plus riches finalement
d'entre nous c'est pas toujours plus
cher cela dit c'est pas toujours plus
cher
par exemple les plats sont peut-être un
peu plus chers oui alors d'abord
l'objectif c'est vraiment de soutenir
nos producteurs donc ce qu'il faut c'est
que à la fin de l'exercice le producteur
lui s'y retrouve et que soit pas le prix
producteur qui soit un revu à la baisse
c'est ça me semble important de le
rappeler quand même
ensuite vous allez mettre en place des
aides pour aider les producteurs alors
on en a déjà on va les retravailler on
votera une délibération cadre sur nos
aides agricoles on a déjà un certain
nombre d'aide ce qui est difficile c'est
qu'on est très contraint par l'Union
européenne en la matière il y a des
plafonds de minimis c'est un peu techno
mais on peut pas faire ce qu'on veut et
on peut pas faire avec les montants
qu'on veut donc c'est en plus la région
est déjà il y a déjà des aides
dans la région sur les leaders par
exemple les projets leaders ancien naval
en plateau de Saclay le département est
partenaire de la région
est-ce que face à la crise économique et
face à au réchauffement climatique
notamment est-ce qu'il va y avoir des
aides en plus il y en a déjà et on va
retravailler notre dispositif d'aide je
peux pas vous dire ce qui lancera
exactement parce que le cadre est pas
encore défini et la fin de ses assises
finalement n'est pas une fin c'est le
démarrage de la mise en œuvre des
propositions de tout ou partie plutôt
des propositions qui ont été faites en
la matière mais pour répondre à votre
question initiale pour réduire les coûts
une petite méthode c'est par exemple
alors on parle beaucoup de d'augmenter
la part de protéines végétales dans les
assiettes et
pourquoi pas puisque s'il y a plus de
protéines végétales ça coûte un peu
moins cher que de la protéine animale ce
qui permet en contrepartie d'envisager
peut-être moins de protéines animales
mais de la protéine animale locale et
donc de soutenir la filière élevage on
n'est pas un département d'élevage mais
ça permet peut-être de renforcer et de
structurer un peu plus fortement une
filière qui a quand même
quelques producteurs sur le territoire
et des outils de transformation
aujourd'hui il y a des filières à
reconstruire à bâtir où il y a déjà des
filières qui sont vraiment en place dans
le département il y a des zones
maraîchères quand même on sait que le
département des Yvelines aussi est une
forte terre céréalière avec le blé le
colza mais il y a quand même des zones
qui sont maraîchères dans le département
des îles et des gens en place là-dessus
sont en place on peut les renforcer on
a des producteurs qui sont prêts à faire
plus
sous réserve qu'en face on leur
garantisse des quantités livrables si on
augmente la part de local dans les
assiettes des collégiens on va avoir
besoin d'avoir plus de sources de
producteurs parce que si une année on a
une mauvaise récolte il faut bien qu'on
ait les quantités de carottes je
reprends l'exemple de la carotte
disponible donc il y a à la fois des
filières à reconstruire je peux enfin à
renforcer je pense à l'élevage hier
j'étais à la région on parlait des
champignons voilà il y a un petit reste
de filière en Île-de-France si on
pouvait la préserver ce serait quand
même formidable que des champignons de
Paris viennent de région parisienne
voilà il y a tous ces enjeux je crois
même qu'il en reste deux il en reste et
trois en Île-de-France juste toute
dernière question Pauline vinocourt
Lefebvre quand est-ce que c'est solution
pour être visible dans le département
quand est-ce qu'elles vont être mises en
place très rapidement il y a déjà des
choses qui sont qui sont en place ou en
expérimentation la délibération cadre
agricole ça devrait être avant la fin de
l'année pour le reste en fonction de ce
qu'on arrive à faire des contraintes
qu'on parviendra à lever de la vitesse à
laquelle on pourra le faire mais
évidemment le plus vite possible très
bien merci beaucoup Pauline vinocourt
Lefebvre d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je le rappelle vous êtes la
vice-présidente déléguée à
l'alimentation pour le département des
Yvelines